A universal health app platform to support
informatics-based innovations in care delivery,
no matter what the underlying EMR was
a long held dream of the Academic Health Informatics community.
In 2010, the Office of the National Coordinator of Health IT awarded
$15 million to the Boston Children's Hospital Computational Health Informatics Program,
and the Harvard Medical School Department of Biomedical Informatics
to create and initially develop just such an app platform.
The result was SMArt,
an acronym for Substitutable Medical Apps,
reusable technology, and open standards
based technology with a robust community of app developers.
A group of health care organizations joined
the smart advisory committee to support the effort through philanthropy,
strategic guidance, and deployment of the technology.